based on the CIA's data the country with
the highest life expectancy is Monaco
with an average of eighty nine point
five years old in the United States it
drops to about eighty in Canada about
eighty-two in the United Kingdom around
eighty one across the world this number
can fluctuate dramatically and drop all
the way down to the low 50s in certain
less developed countries but for the
sake of this video let's assume your
life expectancy is on the higher side of
the world's average and that you will
have no incidents of health
complications or tragedies and that you
will live to 82 years old 82 years on
this planet as yourself not too bad but
that's from birth in terms of your
remaining time in life we have to
subtract however old you are right now
from 82 for the sake of this video let's
say you are 22 years old as that is
generally an age when a lot of people
fully begin their careers after
subtracting that at this point you now
have 60 more potential years of life
which equates to twenty one thousand
nine hundred days or 525,600 hours still
not too bad but if you get an average of
eight hours of sleep per night 175
thousand two hundred of those hours
disappear and you now have just less
than what is equal to 40 years of waking
life left that brings your life
expectancy down 20 years that's kind of
scary but it gets a lot scarier if the
following is true for you a 2017 survey
indicated that about 50% of US workers
described themselves as unsatisfied or
unhappy in their job in another 2017
study conducted worldwide when asked
anonymously 85 percent of workers
admitted to disliking or hating their
job at such a large percentage it is
rather likely that one of these people
might be you or perhaps you don't
necessarily hate or dread your job but
you find yourself rarely ever enjoying
it or feeling inspired by it and are
always wishing for the weekend always
wanting the week to be over and for it
to be Friday night if this is the case
in your life enjoyment is based almost
entirely on the weekend let's see what
happens when we subtract all the
weekdays from your remaining 40 years of
life there is an average of 260 work
days in a year not including holidays
after subtracting those across your
remaining 40 years your number of days
goes from 14,600 all the way down to
4,200 leaving you with only about 11
years but if you figure you retire at an
average age of around 63 you might say
that you should get some of those days
back but if you also figure that in the
u.s. the chance of having a disability
or mental impairment is 68 percent for
people over the age of 65 then this age
isn't exactly a time of your life to
hold out for and claim as years filled
with happiness and enjoyment so in fact
I would argue that in terms of desirable
life we should actually take at least a
portion of those days away first let's
give you them all back but then let's
consider that after the age of 65 as you
grow older and older the likelihood of
developing health conditions or having
existing health conditions worsen only
increases so as a rough generalized
average across all the years after
retirement all the way up until death
let's say a person has somewhere around
two good healthy enjoyable days out of
every seven now you are exactly right
back where you were with eleven years of
remaining life in living for the weekend
you went from what first sounded like a
decent 60 years of remaining life all
the way down to only 11 and as an extra
kicker what if you have weekends that
aren't that good weekends where you have
to do things that you don't want to do
like house chores yard work dealing with
annoying personal stuff or even going
into work to catch up on things that's
at least another year or more off of
your remaining life if you are
twenty-two your waking life expectancy
for life you want to live is now
equivalent to around the age of 32
regardless of your age who you are what
you do or the exact accuracy of these
numbers to your life if you live for the
weekends
the point holds true the idea that
anyone would accept to live a life where
this amount of it is wished away we're
such a huge quantity of time is spent
not wanting that time to happen we're
such a small percentage is spent
enjoying it and living in the moment for
anyone that has any sliver of hope in
not living like this
it is borderline insanity to accept sure
there are responsibilities we must
attend to in life sure there are things
we're going to have to do that we don't
always want to do sure every day of our
job in career can always be fun or how
we want it to be but to work a job or be
in a career or be at a company that you
don't enjoy or find fulfillment in at
least a majority of the time you're
essentially signing away most of
life life is extremely short if you do
out all of the math and consider every
little trivial or self maintenance
oriented thing we spend time doing even
if you love what you do for work and
don't subtract all the weekdays from
your remaining life the time we have is
still frightening ly short so it truly
is so important that we do not give it
away that we are careful and conscious
of what we exchange it for that we do
not let outside pressures from family
friends or society convinced us to just
give it away blindly and choose jobs
careers companies or lifestyles that we
don't personally enjoy or resonate with
that we don't become easily distracted
or persuaded by short-term glitz and
glamour that we know we don't really
need and that we try our best to avoid
accepting anything less we're making big
mistakes that forced us to have to if
you feel like you are constantly wishing
for the weekend only for it to come and
then in a blink of the eye it ends in
your back at the same starting point on
Monday waiting for the weekend all over
again if you feel like you are anywhere
close to living a life where you dislike
almost every day of what you do throwing
each day into the trash of waste of time
perhaps you should spend some of your
time trying to figure out how to make
sure you don't waste any more of it
[Music]
thank you for watching if you found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel we are constantly coming out
with new videos to help you experience
life with clarity and Wonder